u.s and ukrainian officials say as many
as 130 000 russian troops are now
deployed near ukraine's border mts taya
reports from ukraine on how the
country's military is preparing for a
potential invasion
they may be out gunned
and out man
but the ukrainian military says
if forced it will fight
this tank unit is running tactical
drills near the russian border
but ukrainian forces will need more than
anti-tank units to face russia's
military might the weak point of ukraine
and military is the air ukrainian army
veteran yuri zabanovsky says ukraine
lacks the ability to track and intercept
the tactical missiles in russia's
arsenal
and all the ukrainian territory is in
range of those missiles deployed in
belarus crimea and russia
this is a nation that knows war in kiev
the memory wall of the fallen defenders
stretches as long as a city block
for eight long years ukrainian forces
have been battling russian-backed
separatists in the east claiming 14 000
lives
as the threat of an invasion continues
to hang over this city
president vladimir putin's plans may be
more about extracting concessions than
triggering a major military conflict
says russian military analyst alexander
bonnell escalation the fear of the
war
is a
working political instrument to make
russian demands and russian concerns to
be to be listened to
now in some ways vladimir putin has what
he wants world powers negotiating his
security demands to prevent war but the
risk in this coercive diplomacy is that
if russia doesn't gain something soon it
may feel it has to use force to not look
weak tony
mts tie up for us in ukraine mts thank
you very much